[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PATTING KNEES]
If you don't get physically ill
seeing your first rough cut,
something's wrong.
You always think you're not
going to get physically ill,
but you do.
[LAUGHS] Well, if you're
taking this class,
you should have the
bravery and ignorance
of wanting to get
something done.
[BELL RING]
People think it's good
editing if you can see it.
Good editing is something else
too, where you don't see it.
Sometimes, you think something
is dreadfully wrong, and later
and you look at in the
context of a cut, might work.
Well, in the case of
production design,
when you take it to
casino, the excess
is what the film's about.
The manic nature of it,
splashiness of the whole thing.
We knew that it had a
certain quality to it that
is contrasted later with the
confrontations between Joe
Pesci and Bob De Niro,
and just the two of them
in the desert arguing.
You feel the change,
there's nothing there.
[MECHANICAL NOISES]
If the actors want to take
a scene certain place,
I'll go with him there.
There are things I know
don't work immediately,
but you shoot it,
because it's a process.
If you had the
time on set, I like
to tell the actors to try
anything, add the time to fail.
Just go ahead, try
this, try that.
You need that freedom, you
need give them that freedom.
Well of course
when I was younger,
we didn't have cameras,
and that sort of thing,
it was too expensive.
This world of movie making,
where these miraculous images
and stories came from
really felt very distant.
I had a teacher.
He was the one to
give me the confidence
to become a filmmaker, to
come from this other world
and suddenly be able
to express myself.
If the machinery of it all
seems too big, and scary,
and overwhelming, it's great.
You wake up in the morning
and you do it anyway.
You have to learn
it yourself, you
have to learn it going
through that process.
That's the greatest thing any
teacher could give a student.
The confidence and the
inspiration to make you think,
well, it's crazy, but
maybe I can do it.
Now it's time to get to work.
I'm Martin Scorsese, and
this is my MasterClass.